the word islam can best be translated
into english as meaning surrender and in
the context of the islamic faith it's
referring to a surrender to the will of
god
now a muslim is someone who practices
islam one who submits to the will of god
and the central text in islam is the
quran which muslims believe is the
revealed knowledge or the revealed words
of god through the messenger muhammad
now it's very important sometimes
especially an older text older western
text you might see islam referred to as
the same way that
christianity refers to christ now
muslims are very sensitive to this
because they don't view muhammad as a
divine figure the way that christians
view christ they view muhammad as a
human a human whose practices and whose
life they view they revere but they
don't view him as a divine figure they
view him as the messenger who revealed
god's words through the quran and they
take this so seriously
in most muslim traditions they don't
create images of muhammad for fear that
people would start to worship it as some
type of an idol
now on
this timeline you see other significant
judeo-christian
figures and that's because according to
muslims they are following in the same
tradition of these figures they view
these other figures as people who have
submitted to the will of god and moses
and jesus in particular are the most
frequently mentioned prophets in the
quran
now muslims also believe
that the quran isn't the first book that
god had revealed to mankind they also
believe that the torah which is the
first five books of the hebrew bible and
also the first five books of the
christian old testament genesis exodus
leviticus numbers and deuteronomy they
believe that to be a revealed text from
god through the prophet moses
they also believe that psalms is a
revealed text from god through king
david so through the prophet david who
lived around 1000 bce
and they think that the gospel is a
revealed message through
jesus
now above and beyond these revealed
texts another significant part of the
muslim tradition or faith are the
notions of sunnah and hadith and sunnah
are the practices and life and sayings
of muhammad and many of them are
accounted for in the hadith hadith are
second-hand accounts of other people who
lived at the time of muhammad although
many of them were written decades or
sometimes hundreds of years later and so
it is a debate in the muslim community
on which hadiths are considered more
trustworthy than others the one
commonality regardless of sect is the
centrality of the quran and viewing that
as the actual word of god
to see this a little bit more concretely
in terms of how much muslims view
themselves as the same tradition that we
see from the old and new testament here
are some
quranic quotes
and the first one essentially speaks to
this core idea of being in that same
tradition
he has ordained for you of religion what
he enjoined upon noah and that which we
have revealed to you o muhammad and what
we enjoined upon abraham and moses and
jesus to establish the religion and not
be divided therein
and this is speaking to the importance
of abraham and who is better in religion
than one who submits himself to god
while being a doer of good and follows
the religion of abraham inclining toward
truth and god took abraham as a friend
and abraham in particular plays a very
central role the kaaba which muslims
view as the house of god based in mecca
right over here is
viewed as being built by abraham and
ishmael and so madinah which is where in
future videos we'll talk more about
where the early muslims sought exile to
escape persecution that's often viewed
as the city of muhammad but mecca which
is the direction that all muslims pray
in during their ritual five times a day
prayer which we'll talk about a little
bit that's often referred to as the city
of abraham
and now here's reference to moses
and before it was the scripture of moses
to lead and as a mercy and this is a
confirming book in an arabic tongue so
this this being the quran this is a
quote from the quran and this is a
confirming book in an arabic tongue to
warn those who have wronged and as good
tidings to the doers of good so once
again a very clear
message and at least the islamic
tradition
that this is the same faith or tradition
as that of moses
and now here's reference to jesus
then we caused our messengers to follow
in their footsteps and we caused jesus
son of mary to follow and gave him the
gospel and placed compassion and mercy
in the hearts of those who followed him
the key difference between muslims and
christians in terms of the life of jesus
is that muslims do not believe in the
crucifixion and the resurrection and
they do not believe that jesus was god
or the son of god they believed him to
be a very significant prophet the
prophet before muhammad came to reveal
the quran
now for a practicing muslim they are
often considered to be five pillars and
this is especially the case in for the
majority of muslims for sunni muslims
shia muslims have a slightly different
combination combination of pillars but
there's a lot of commonality
so the five pillars the first is this
notion of faith which is referred to as
shahaban shahadah can also be
interpreted as testifying or testimony
and it's this notion that a muslim needs
to believe and say that there is no god
but god muhammad is god's messenger and
in fact to convert to islam you need to
say this and you have to say it in the
presence of at least two witnesses and
that's all that's necessary in order to
convert
now the other key element of islam the
second you could say of the five pillars
is this notion of prayer so muslims pray
five times a day at dawn noon in the
afternoon evening and night and they
face in the direction of the kaaba which
is based in mecca which once again they
believe that abraham constructed with
his son ishmael
who they believe that the arab people
are descendant from
now what's interesting about this this
has a lot of parallels with the five
times a day prayer of the zoroastrians
including the ritual washing of your
body before each prayer
now the third pillar is charity and it's
called zakat and this is customarily two
and a half percent of wealth now two and
a half percent might not sound like a
lot but this isn't of income this is of
wealth
the fourth pillar is the notion of
fasting dawn to dusk during the ninth
month of the islamic calendar and that
month is ramadan and it's fasting
without food or water once again from
dawn to dusk and the islamic calendar is
a lunar calendar and the notion of a
month in fact in english it comes from
the word moon because it's referring to
a full cycle of the moon
now the end of this month ends with the
eid al-fitr which is the festival of
breaking the fast which is considered
one of the two major holidays in islam
now the fifth pillar of islam is the
notion of pilgrimage to the kaaba during
the 12th month and it's during a certain
period in that 12th month and then also
in that 12th month you have the second
major holiday in islam and that's
the festival of the sacrifice and that
once again is making reference to
abraham and his willingness to sacrifice
his son before god stops him
so this is the general idea of islam in
other videos we're going to go into much
more detail in terms of how it started
the life of the muslim prophet muhammad
in mecca and madinah and then how it
spread through the world shortly after
or even during the life of muhammad in
the 6th and 7th centuries of the common
era